House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022. Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan
Condal will serve as showrunners and executive
producers.
George R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It’s based on George RR Martin’s Targaryen
history book Fire And Blood volume 1
and on Martin’s yet unfinished Fire And
Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
Thats Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Vlood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
The key event of the prequel will be the Dance
of the Dragon, a Targaryen civil war.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
The war of succession between Aegon II and
his half-sister Rhaenyra over their father
Viserys I's throne.
Targaryens fought Targaryens, brothers fought
brothers, dragons fought dragons.
Most of Westeros waged war in either support
of Queen Rhaenyra and became known as the
''blacks''
or in support of her rival King Aegon II and
became known as the ''greens'',
and by the time it was over dozens of thousands
were dead,
most of the dragons were killed as well as
most of Targaryens.
The biggest supporter of King Aegon II and
the man who fought the most for the ''greens''
as well as burned the most of Westeros in
this war, was King Aegon's brother Aemond.
Prince Aemond Targaryen, also known as Aemond
One-Eye or Aemond the Kinslayer,
was a Prince of the Targaryen dynasty who
rode the most powerful dragon of its time,
mighty Vhagar.
Vhagar was a she-dragon of House Targaryen.
She was ridden by Queen Visenya Targaryen
during Aegon's Conquest,
alongside Aegon the Conqueror's Balerion and
their sister Rhaenys's Meraxes.
Prince Aemond and his dragon Vhagar played
a major role in the Targaryen civil war.
By the time of the Dance of the Dragons, Vhagar
was the hardened survivor of a hundred battles,
had grown almost as large as Balerion, and
was the oldest and largest of dragons in Westeros.
Her roar was so powerful that it could shake
the very foundations of Storm's End.
No living dragon could match her for size
or ferocity.
Born in 110 AC, Aemond was the second son
of King Viserys I Targaryen and Queen Alicent
Hightower and the brother of King Aegon II
Targaryen.
At birth, Aemond was said to be half the size
his older brother, Aegon, had been,
although he was twice as fierce.
The births of Aemond and his older brother
Aegon were the cause of some strife at the
court of Viserys I. The king had named Rhaenyra,
his only surviving child by his first marriage,
his official heir in 105 AC, but refused to
change the order of succession after the birth
of two healthy sons.
This eventually led to the rise of the "queen's
party" at the royal court,
as opposed to the "princess's party".
In 120 AC, when Aemond was ten years old,
his brother-in-law, Ser Laenor Velaryon, died.
Aemond accompanied his parents and siblings
to Driftmark to attend Laenor's funeral.
King Viserys had suggested traveling to Dragonstone
after the funeral, and informed Aemond,
who out of all his siblings was the only one
yet without a dragon of his own,
that he could claim a dragon egg or hatchling
on Dragonstone for his own, if he was "bold
enough". Annoyed by his father's comment,
Aemond resolved to claim Vhagar, the oldest
and largest living dragon, who had recently
become riderless with the death of Laena Velaryon.
Vhagar was present on Driftmark,
and Aemond who knew that his parents would
not allow him near the dragon,
went to make his attempt in secret. Aemond
was caught by his three-year-old nephew, Prince
Joffrey.
In an attempt to keep him quiet, Aemond slapped
and threatened the younger boy before shoving
him into a pile of dragon droppings. When
Joffrey began to yell, Aemond climbed on top
of Vhagar's back. The dragon broke free of
her chains, and Aemond flew two circles before
landing.
Joffrey, however, had alarmed his two older
siblings, Jacaerys and Lucerys Velaryon.
The four boys fought with wooden training
swords, until Aemond called his nephews "Strongs"
as it was rumored they were bastards of their
mother's lover Ser Harwin Strong,
having their rumored father's appearance rather
than Valyrian appearance of House Targaryen
or Velaryion. Jacaerys, old enough to understand
the insult, attacked Aemond again.
When Aemond gained the upper hand and began
to beat Jacaerys savagely,
Lucerys drew his dagger and slashed at Aemond's
face, taking out his right eye.
After the incident, Queen Alicent called for
Lucerys to lose an eye as penance,
which King Viserys refused, while Princess
Rhaenyra demanded that Aemond was questioned,
"sharply", until he revealed where he heard
her sons being described as "Strongs" –
as naming them such was suggesting they were
bastards,
and therefore that Rhaenyra was guilty of
high treason by sleeping with Ser Harwin Strong.
Forced by his father, Aemond eventually admitted
hearing the name from his brother, Prince
Aegon.
While he was an unforgiving person, Aemond
would later say that he considered losing
an eye
to be a fair trade in an exchange for obtaining
the great Vhagar.
Afterward he often put a smoothed sapphire
as a false eye in his empty socket.
Despite the loss of his eye, Aemond went on
to become one of the most fearsome swordsmen
in all of Westeros, as he spent the next ten
years being trained by Ser Criston Cole, Lord
Commander of the Kingsguard.
On the first day of 127 AC, King Viserys held
a feast to celebrate the return of his health.
After the King had left the feast, Aemond
toasted his three Velaryon cousins,
speaking of their appearance, mocking them
as "three Strong boys".
Aemond wore night-black armor, chased with
gold.
In 129 AC, when Aemond was nineteen years
old, his father, King Viserys I Targaryen
died.
Aemond's older brother was crowned King Aegon
II Targaryen despite their older sister Rhaenyra
having been Viserys's chosen heir, starting
the war of succession known as the Dance of
the Dragons.
At the beginning of the war Aemond flew Vhagar
to Storm's End
to win the loyalty of Lord Borros Baratheon
by wedding one of his daughters.
Rhaenyra's second son Lucerys also arrived
on his dragon Arrax,
with the same goal of winning over the Baratheons.
Lucerys, however, only asked Borros to join
Rhaenyra for the sake of his past oaths,
and said he could not wed one of his daughters
because he was already betrothed so Borros
spurned his offer.
When Aemond threatened Lucerys, stating he
owed him an eye,
Borros refused to allow them to fight under
his roof.
Borros's men restrained Aemond, allowing Lucerys
to leave the hall
and take off on his dragon, Arrax. When Borros's
daughter Maris taunted Aemond,
asking him if Lucerys had removed his balls
as well as his eye, Aemond became enraged.
When he asked Borros's leave, Borros told
Aemond that he had no say about what Aemond
did
while not underneath Borros's roof, and allowed
him to depart.
Aemond mounted Vhagar and pursued his cousin,
avenging the loss of his eye by killing Lucerys
and Arrax. Mushroom claims Aemond located
the boy's corpse and removed both of his eyes
to present them to Lady Maris on a bed of
seaweed.
Aemond was known thereafter as a kingslayer
among his enemies.
His own mother, Alicent Hightower and grandfather
Otto Hightower were horrified by Aemond's
actions; they'd still hoped the war might
be ended diplomatically, but by killing one
of her sons, Aemond had ensured Rhaenyra would
fight to the bitter end.
Otto Hightower famously told him ''You only
lost one eye, how could you be so blind?''
Aemond and Vhagar's next major fight was in
the Battle of Rook's Rest,
where Aegon II's armies set a trap for Rhaenys
Targaryen riding the dragon Maelys.
When she arrived she was ambushed two-on-one
by Aegon II riding Sunfyre and Aemond on Vhagar.
Even so, Maelys was a large dragon and did
not go down without a fight:
at the end of their fall to the ground, Vhagar
was relatively unharmed,
but Sunfyre was crippled and nearly killed.
Aegon II himself was burned over half of his
body,
leaving him semi-conscious for the next full
year as he slowly recovered.
In his stead, at Alicent's behest Aemond stepped
up to become Prince Regent
and Protector of the Realm.
As Prince Regent, Aemond gathered an army
together with Ser Criston Cole, the Hand of
the King.
Now in command, Aemond demonstrated that as
a swordsman and a dragonrider he was a deadly
opponent, but also a hothead with no sense
of strategy.
He decided that the real threat was not Rhaenyra
on Dragonstone to the east,
but the main armies of her supporters massing
under his uncle Daemon at Harrenhal.
Therefore, he led out all of Aegon II's remaining
armies in the Crownlands north to attack Harrenhall
- leaving the capital city with only a skeleton
defense.
Daemon however had planned on this and simply
abandoned Harrenhal,
his army moving to the west where it destroyed
the Lannisters' armies.
Meanwhile, Daemon himself flew his dragon
to King's Landing,
where Rhaenyra's small fleet in the east,
augmented by dragons,
was able to capture the lightly defended city.
There was no siege, as the City Watch were
loyal to Daemon
and supported Daemon as soon as he appeared.
He made his niece and wife, Rhaenyra, the
Queen of the Seven Kingdoms.
Aemond arrived at Harrenhal to find an empty
castle, and quickly heard the news of the
loss of King's Landing as well as destruction
of their forces in the west.
Aemond was driven into such a rage at his
failure that he nearly killed the messenger
who brought the news. In petty revenge he
then used Vhagar to burn every wooden structure
in Harrenhal –
the second time the castle was blasted by
dragonflame.
Aemond then impetuously abandoned his main
army to launch a one-man / one-dragon war
against Rhaenyra's followers in the Riverlands,
burning out entire towns and personally destroying
vast swaths of territory.
With him he took his bedmate, the seer Alys
Rivers. While devastating, even this proved
to be folly:
the army he had taken north to Harrenhal was
left to retreat south through the Riverlands,
with no dragon to defend it. Rhaenyra's forces
in the region managed to loop around from
defeating the Lannisters and surround Cole's
army: outnumbered three to one Aegon II's
remaining army was wiped out in a decisive
battle, and Cole himself killed.
Daemon hunted long for Aemond and Vhagar,
but Aemond would flee ahead of him and other
searchers - he knew that Vhagar could kill
any dragon in a one on one fight, and his
hit-and-run attacks would draw out two or
three of Rhaenyra's other dragons from other
fronts in the war as they hunted him in vain.
Eventually, despairing of the war, Daemon
waited alone with his dragon Caraxes in the
ruins of Harrenhal as a challenge to Aemond
– knowing that Aemond would only face him
in a one-on-one fight
he thought he could win because his dragon
was the oldest and biggest of the remaining
dragons,
being almost the size of Balerion, but he
was wrong as Daemon's dragon was just as fierce
and battle proven. Aemond could never dare
to duel Daemon 1 on 1 with a sword on foot
as Daemon was the best warrior in this time
period and Aemond knew it,
but Aemond had another advantage - Vhagar
- but not even that was enough to beat Daemon.
After thirteen days Aemond arrived, along
with a pregnant Alys.
She stayed on the ground as Aemond and Daemon
took to the air for the final, mighty duel
between Vhagar and Caraxes.
In Aemond's final exchange with his uncle
Daemon, he said to him "You have lived too
long, uncle."
and Daemon replied "On that much, we agree."
It was an aerial duel that took place in the
skies above Harrenhal and the Gods Eye
between two of the most powerful living dragons,
Vhagar and Caraxes,
and their riders, Prince Aemond and Prince
Daemon Targaryen.
The duel was said to be a sight to see. The
sun was setting as the two dragons took to
the sky.
So bright was the dragonfire that smallfolk
feared the sky was aflame.
When Caraxes attacked Vhagar, she ripped upon
his stomach and tore one of his wings,
but then Caraxes fastened his jaws around
her throat in a death grip.
These injuries forced them both to cease flying
and as they tumbled to the water below,
Daemon dueled Aemond to death.
At the climax of the fight, as he never fastened
his saddle, Daemon stood up on Caraxes
and leaped at Aemond, whereupon he drove his
Dark Sister through Aemond's eye
and through his neck, just a second before
hitting the water.
Aemond's body that was still chained to the
saddle, went underwater along with Vhagar,
was only recovered years after the war, with
Dark Sister still impaled through his skull.
The Battle Above the Gods Eye ended in the
deaths of both riders and both dragons.
Aemond was 20 years old when he died.
Daemon was forty-nine when he died.
Unlike Aemond's body, however, Daemon's was
never found.
Singers say that Daemon lived to spend the
rest of his days in secret with Nettles,
but most historians disagree.
What happened to Aemond's child with Alys
as well as with Alys herself remains yet to
be seen.
Aemond is definitely going to be one of the
most important characters in the upcoming
prequel show.
Let me know your thoughts about all of this
in the comment section down below.
Thank you so much for watching, if you enjoyed
this video please give it a big thumbs up
and I hope to see you in the next one. Peace!